[Musique]
la maison blanche
est tombé
une attaque a dessiné la capitale
britannique
vous devez vraiment aimé la pêche
monsieur le président on se les gèle et
c'est que les jeux seraient prêts à tout
pour échapper un moment à washington
c'est quoi ça des chauves souris des
drôles
les arrêts sur toi mark segal on any
pour conclure le monsieur aspirait coup
le président a été victime mick fanning
vous êtes accusé d'avoir voulu abattre
le président des états unis
l'ange gardien du président a été arrêté
vous ne voyez pas qu'on a voulu me
piéger
[Musique]
y'a quelqu'un doté rien ça je suis
innocent le président est en danger ils
vont essayer de finir le travail et je
m'arrêterai qu'une fois que je tiendrai
le coupable
comment tu m'as trouvé je m'occupe de la
sécurité du président qu'est ce que tu
crois pas j'ai besoin de ton aide
[Musique]
vous échapperez pas paniqué si vous me
trouvez pas c'est pas grave moi je vous
retrouverai
ecoutez-moi va falloir faire vite hein
pas y avoir de victime
ce n'est pas vrai
ce sont les combats que nous livrons
dino définissent
[Musique]